all right layman
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally where were you born i'm
from uh hilton kentucky that's where you
were born
yeah i've been born right that's a pearl
rather
half a mile out here i'll take you up
here and show you i'd love to see it a
house
225 years old that's why i was born in
the bed
a shield bed is uh
it's still up there that me and my
sister was born then there's two of us
left
you're old huh i'm 90 years
and two months going on 92.
that's great i'm 91 i mean you're great
so tell me about your childhood you grew
up with both your parents yeah
yeah how how was your childhood
when my father i i i was five-year-old
when my
when my dad died oh i'm sorry five years
old
yeah i just remember him a time or two
taking me to the post
to the store down there and buy me some
candy
i bet i missed him
you know pretty bad but uh my father was
in the spanish american war
and uh we got pictures of him up there
i'll they'll take you all up there and
show you this house where i was born
they got pictures of him up there and
how did you lose your father my father
back then they didn't have much
hospital he died died in the red bird
hospital died with
some kind of uh i i guess it was cancer
i don't know what killed him
really they didn't have much doctors
then
uh but didn't have no uh had to come to
red bird it's about
from here to red bird had to carry him
on stretchers
and his five men
carried him over he lived in the
hospital
for about a week and died of work
and they had to go and carry him back we
didn't have no vehicles
uh had to come back on stretchers and uh
they buried him down here they held him
post office down here about a mile
so tell me about how you grew up did you
have electricity you didn't have water
you didn't have anything you know
well you know like i grew up we didn't
have an old bathroom in the house we had
a
toilet like that out this is a regular
toilet outside the house
and of course we didn't have any water
in the house we uh
had a big whale up here after
after you interview me i'll take you all
over and show you
i had to draw water have a had a rope
and and a pulley and
drove the water out of the wheel and
back then
uh you raised most of the food that you
eat
in the summertime and put it up doing uh
for winter like cabbages and potatoes
and
something like that uh but
no and i i told you
i think before that i i i've worked
for my uncle up here he worked me like
very very hard for 25 cents
from six o'clock to six at night
and uh one time you know
uh we took a load of of timbers to a
mine over there in harlem kentucky
and i i thought sure that
he he had killed he drawed a pension he
had he had
money but you know he wouldn't even buy
me
a 10-cent hot dog and a nickel
pup i had to sit there and
they eat a big dinner him and their son
and i had to sit there and
drink water i mean you know it was hard
for me to believe that he
wouldn't spend uh you know 15 cents
and i told him that he would buy me a
uh a hot dog and uh
a a small pup back then was just a
nickel
and he said well you don't get paid till
but he just wouldn't do it anyway but
well uh and after after
that we came back home i told my mother
about that she said son i can't believe
it
him he drove a pension that he wouldn't
buy you
a 10-10 hot dog and a nickel pop
and but you know
i uh after i decided i
i told mother i decided i want to go for
the army
but anyway she said son you know i said
uh i have to tell them i'm 17 and you
have to back it up
to a recruiting officer and she said i
i don't want you to go but i didn't
i told i'll be about to go and try it we
didn't have any vehicle back then
we had to go down here and ed wilson a
cousin of mine drove the black brothers
and boys
we got on that black brother's bus and
uh
went to harlem she went with me she
decided she would do that
i got over that recruiting officer and
told him i was 17 years old
how old were you actually he said huh
how old were you actually
13. i was 13. but you have to be 17
before you get in the united states army
and that recruiting officer said mr
wilson
you look very very young and said i
don't believe you are 17 years old you
know
i said yes my mother's out there in the
waiting room
to him and uh you go out there and ask
her
how old i am i told her what to tell him
you know
and she said you know he asked her and
she said uh he's 17.
and uh well
he said well i'll tell you what
you go come here in the morning mr wills
weather out of bus like i said before
and uh
and i i'll have you a a ticket made to
camp attlebury indiana
and uh you go up there and have an
examination
see if you pay for the army well i went
over the next morning
in colorado i've never been anywhere out
of the state of kentucky
but anyway i went to camp atterbury
indiana
i caught a train and went up there and
i i when i got up there i didn't have
much money i had
i i can't remember what my 25
30 old money i had but anyway
you know i i went to a taxi
cab outfit and i didn't know
you know where that place was he drove
me a
hundred miles and took about all the
money that i had
and uh i went in there and uh
and to be examined and
i was examined and and uh this
recruiting officer said
to me uh that uh
i didn't look like i was 17 you know but
anyway
he said he said we need men uh
you say you're 17 your mother said you
will i guess it's
all this past year and i tell you that
they passed me and uh he's he sent me to
camp edelberg in
indiana like i said that i was exhaling
and
i was 10 pound on the weight but they
passed me anyway
so i i went from camp attlebury in
indiana to fort knox kentucky for for
basic training i was in basic training
in fort knox
for three months and
i came uh i came home on leave
and for 14 days and then they sent me to
the
southwest south pacific uh
uh 100 miles out of
manila i forget the baggy over the name
of that place was
and i drove took her for two years
i stayed two years and then i
got discharged i come back and got a job
in my mind
and and went to work how many years of
school did you get
how many years of school did you get
eighth grade eighth grade
well what it was i started high school
but anyway
i got over and these young fellas i was
about 18 or 20 years old there's three
of them
they got jails for me over a girl
there went to school and they broke the
door down
and and come in there and almost
beat me to death the principal was
downstairs he helped me hear it or they
would have killed me
and but anyway uh
he got him off of me and i left the next
morning
uh from school over at red bird
and i i didn't go i came
to the army and then eventually after
the army
you worked as a coal miner yeah i worked
in the coal mines yeah yeah
and growing up in appalachia what uh
what would have been the most
difficult parts of living in appalachia
well i tell you look
back when we got there that cure you
know we didn't have no
no no juice had to use a lamp white you
know
and of course didn't have no water in
the house and
back when it raised up it was it was
pretty
hard i tell you and no roads in here but
the road went up to his creek here
it was a long time before they built a
roll up there
uh but our road
came up this creek up there while born
and raised at this house right out here
uh but uh we didn't have no roads didn't
have
much of you walked there where you went
well there were no vehicles back there
right there were no vehicles back there
nope no
how'd you get around uh roller
knew that's trap station wasn't
i don't know my dad had
some fine team of mules and he'd worked
them and
uh that's how we got around to
roll the mule when you were a young man
did you have dreams of doing something
with your life i decided you know when i
was a young man i
i thought i might try to retire in the
army ready and really you know i was
young i was
like i said told you i was 13
about i told my 17 but after i stayed
two years i decided i'd get out and i
get out and got a job
and been of course i've been [ __ ]
you know a long time
have you ever considered of leaving this
part of the country
and moving somewhere else you know uh my
god
i i got one sister left she lived in
ohio
he didn't want me to come up there but
i've been
born and raised here on this if you're
calling this big brain sure it's how are
you i
i will stay here you're happy here
yeah right you've been here that many
years
i'm like i told you i'm 90 years old in
about two months
uh i too old to leave now
yeah what are your best memories huh
what are your best
memories well i'll tell you what back
when i
i get best memories i've had well you
know
a few were born and raised up here at
this old house
i'm going to take you up there and show
you that before you leave i'd like you
to see
225 years old i guess that's the best
memories i can think of here
i'd love to see it yeah what has been
the most important
technological advancement that's
happened in your life
automobile you know back when i
i never did have that i rolled a mule
all the time i never really have no
vehicles back when i growed up
how would you how would you visit a
doctor or a dentist
well back then i'll tell you one time i
remember
we went me and my sister and these two
of us
we both got pneumonia and uh matt wilson
down here at the mouth is hollering here
uh he had a he had an old emo
car and uh mother
uh called him and he came up here at
this old place up here 225 years old
i came up there and got us and took us
to the hospital
over in in harlan kentucky we
both stayed in there for about seven
eight days with pneumonia
and got help
and what's the most important lesson
you've learned in your 90 years
and i've
well you know i i just think for the old
man above that i
i can still do pretty good to be
90 years and two months old i can still
drive
and stuff you more the lawn still yeah
i'm down pretty good i'll tell you this
one story here
you know uh about six months ago
i was going to uh to harlan over there
and i got stopped on pine mountain by a
state police
he just joined this was on a friday and
he just joined uh
he caught me up there and of course i
had insurance
and everything and he asked me he looked
at my
driver's license he said buddy you too
old to drive aren't you
i said well you can't get anybody to
drive you anytime you want to
and he said why don't you come in uh
that was on a friday he said i want you
to come in monday morning
and give your driver's license up and uh
i said buddy you can't get anybody to
drive you you know
and he said i want you to come in monday
morning and give you a driver's license
he says do you have a anybody
that i could talk to or share a donor or
something
and i got a donor that's a lawyer for
the university of kentucky yeah
i give her my daughter's number i give
him
but anyway he called her he said i got
your dad stopped here on pine mountain
and uh of course he got insurance and
everything
but i'm asking because he's too old to
drive
and she said to him she said let me tell
you something mother
uh what you got him stopped for
he said i inch on the yellow line she
told him
i i could hear her she said let me tell
you something brother
said i'm a lawyer for the university of
kentucky
my son the lawyer and my husband is
circuit judge and she said we'll be
there
monday morning at nine o'clock and we'll
see
she said that's not even a fine
and uh of course he he hung up
and he told me you know uh after he got
done talking to her
he said i'll tell you what i'm gonna do
mr wilson
i'm to follow you to across the pine
mountains
to the philippine mountain and your
daughter says that's not even found but
he said i think it is
well i said i don't know i don't know
and uh i said well you can follow me
full of pine mountain
and he followed me to the philippine
mountain and throw them blue lights back
on me again
and he came out there and said to me he
said
mr wilson i'm sorry i've known you the
way i i've done you
he said you don't have to come in and
give your life and so what that was the
end of it
all right layman well thank you so much
for uh talking with me and sharing your
interesting story
yeah thank you for interviewing me i
appreciate that yeah you've had a great
life
yeah good luck good luck i appreciate
that man
thank you thank you
you